a nutritionist wants to estimate the
average caloric content of the burritos
at a popular restaurant they obtain a
random sample of 14 burritos and measure
their caloric content their sample data
are roughly symmetric with a mean of
seven art calories and a standard
deviation of 50 calories based on this
sample which of the following is a 95%
confidence interval for the mean caloric
content of these burritos so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
alright what's going on here so there's
a population of burritos here there is a
mean caloric content that the
nutritionist wants to figure out but
Kent doesn't know the true population
parameter here the population mean and
so they take a sample of 14 burritos and
they calculate some sample statistics
they calculate the sample mean which is
700 they also calculate the sample
standard deviation which is equal to 50
and they want to use this data to
construct a 95% confidence interval and
so our confidence interval is going to
take the form and we've seen this before
our sample mean plus or minus our
critical value times the sample standard
deviation divided by the square root of
n the reason why we're using a t
statistic is because we don't know the
actual standard deviation for the
population if we knew the standard
deviation for the population we would
use that instead of our sample standard
deviation and if we use that if we used
Sigma which is a population parameter
then we could use a Z statistic right
over here we would use a Z distribution
but since we're using this sample
standard deviation that's why we're
using a t statistic but now let's do
that so what is this going to be so our
sample mean is 700 they tell us that so
it's going to be 700 plus or minus plus
or minus so what would be our critical
value for a 95% confidence interval well
we will just get out our T table and
with a T table remember you have to care
about degrees of freedom and if our
sample size is 14 then that means you
take 14 minus 1 so degrees of freedom is
- one so that's going to be 14 minus one
is equal to 13 so we have 13 degrees of
freedom that we have to keep in mind
when we look at our tea table so let's
look at our tea table
so 95% confidence interval and 13
degrees of freedom so degrees of freedom
right over here so we have 13 degrees of
freedom so that is this row right over
here and if we want a 95% confidence
level then that means our tail
probability remember if our distribution
let me see if I'll draw it really small
a little small distribution right over
here so if you want 95% of the area in
the middle that means you have 5% not
shaded in and that's evenly divided on
each side so that means you have two and
a half percent at the tails two and a
half percent so what you want to look
for is a tail probability of two and a
half percent so that is this right over
here point zero to five that's two and a
half percent and so there you go that is
our critical value two point one six
zero so this so this part right over
here so this is going to be - let me do
that in a darker color this is going to
be two point one six zero times
what's our sample standard deviation
it's 50 over the square root of n square
root of 14 so all of our choices have
the 700 there so we just need to figure
out what our margin of error this part
of it and we could use a calculator for
that okay two point one six you write a
zero there doesn't really matter times
50 divided by the square root of 14
square root of 14 we get a little bit of
a drumroll here I think twenty eight
point eight six so this part right over
here is approximately twenty-eight point
eight six that's our margin of error and
we see out of all of these choices here
if we were round to the nearest tenth
that would be twenty eight point nine
so this is approximately twenty-eight
point nine which is this choice right
over here this was an awfully close one
I guess they're trying to make sure that
we're looking at enough digits so there
we have it we have established our 95%
confidence interval now one thing that
we should keep in mind is is this a
valid confidence interval did we meet
our conditions for a valid confidence
interval and here we have to think well
did we take a random sample and they
tell us that they obtained a random
sample of 14 burritos so we check that
one is the sampling distribution roughly
normal well either you take if you take
over 30 samples than it would be but
here we only took 14 but they do tell us
that the sample data is roughly
symmetric and so if it's roughly
symmetric and it has no significant
outliers then this is reasonable that
you can assume that it is roughly normal
and then the last condition is the
independence condition and here if we
aren't sampling with replacement and it
doesn't look like we are if we're not
sampling with replacement this has to be
less than 10% of this has to be less
than 10% of the population of burritos
and we're assuming that there's going to
be more than 140 burritos that the
universe that the population that this
popular restaurant makes so I think we
can meet the independence condition as
well so suing that you feel good about
constructing a confidence interval this
is the one that you would actually
construct